what is the worst case scenario for
misuse of the warp drive dave owens
what's the worst case quickly misuse of
a warp drive i don't even mean anything
a warp drive does is going to be good
yeah uh so misuse would be you use it to
actually travel back in time and
then you and then you kill your you you
kill your grandparents and then you no
longer exist that's who you are maybe
that'd be fine by the way you don't ever
have to kill your grandparents no you
could just push him down no yeah
prevent him from ever having met yeah
you don't have to be bloody about it you
could in fact you could go back to your
great great great great great
grandparents and change the time they
had sex okay then you will not have to
just literally jump out of a closet and
go wow
and then you probably ruined your whole
timeline okay then a different sperm a
different sperm fertilizes the egg and
you're never born perfect okay sounds
like a plan folks are not creative